Palestinians have lived in Japan Macabre
for decades but Israel wants many of
them gone early on Tuesday Palestinian
residents staged a protest and block
major roads The Desperate Measures aim
to prevent Israeli bulldozers and army
vehicles from entering their
neighborhood and demolishing their homes
we are now protesting in solidarity with
the people who have their homes
threatened by demolition occupation
forces demolished three houses and today
there is a decision to demolish another
we are simple people living here how can
a human live without a house we need
houses for our families and children to
protect them from cold and rain
since Sunday Palestinian residents in
Japanese have received repeated phone
calls from Israeli authorities informing
them that their homes will be demolished
Yad Bashir is one of them he left as
quickly as he could to protect his
family
we received the call yesterday at noon
saying that we must Evacuate the house
because they're coming to demolish my
home at five o'clock in the morning they
threaten us if I didn't evacuate my home
they would not only demolish it but they
would make me pay for the demolition
cost around thirty thousand dollars so I
had to move the furniture and all the
other things with my own hands
the increase in demolitions is happening
at the time of growing tension
last Thursday Israeli forces killed 10
Palestinians in the genuine refugee camp
a Palestinian gunman killed seven
Israelis outside the synagogue the next
day
since then Israel has sent more troops
to the occupied areas and fast tracked
the issue of weapons permissed to
thousands of Israeli civilians it has
also revoked National Insurance rights
identity cars and residency of the
attackers family members however other
Palestinians aren't connected to
violence have had their homes destroyed
human rights groups say it constitutes
Collective punishment Jebel Macabre
located southeast of occupied East
Jerusalem is home to 30 000 Palestinians
for now they managed to keep Israeli
bulldozers away however they are
preparing for Israeli police and
vehicles to return
the demolition of Palestinian homes is
not new last year Israel bulldozed at
least 300 houses belonging to
Palestinian families but the pace of the
demolitions has increased since Israeli
cabinet announced punitive measures and
Palestinians are increasingly on edge
fearing their home could be next week
and occupied East Jerusalem